hotdogs strawberry flavored welcome to
Texas
where Kyle new delhi's fishing technique
is caught nearly a half a million views
come back later a strawberry flavored
hot dog as bait now I'm confused about
that like that's a thing yeah sounds
delicious
what's Kyle angling for hang on
did he just took a real fish I thought
rats and weird monsters lived in series
not fish so have we been hooked by a
fake or as Kyle reeling in a record
catch this is absolutely authentic this
is something that's naturally occurring
what Kyle has caught is a flathead
catfish also called a mud cat the one he
caught as a baby this is a storm drain
so there is no sewage here it's actually
attached to a pond smells fishy
why was the catfish in a storm drain
se-young can't fish like these predators
but that can also be prey even to a
larger fish of the same species and this
storm drain provides a perfect refuge so
they would be safe if it weren't for
Kyle who's waiting for them so how did
the catfish find Kyle's bait in the dark
catfish have an amazing sense of smell
and they can detect something as low as
one part per 10 billion that's one
molecule of strawberry hot dog in ten
billion molecules of water
the catfish have an equally impressive
sense of taste the cat fishes whole body
is covered in 250,000 thai spots they
sometimes known as a swimming top for
example a catfish could taste the pizza
just by sitting on top of the pizza and
then I would send the pizza back because
that is not what I ordered